[inaudible].
Okay,
good afternoon.
Yeah.
Good.
The Labor Day afternoon.
We're not for this.
Where would you be today?
There's a good twi night double header at Yankee Stadium.
Where would you be?
All right.
It does seem strange that Labor Day comes in the second week of classes.
Um,
we've got a lot to do today.
I'm going to try to cover the following topics.
First.
We're going to look at the explosive change in the world economy,
which is in mid stream.
Uh,
your handout is a snapshot of that.
Then we're going to look at heads up there.
There's a handout here,
folks who doesn't have the handout.
Okay?
They're the sources up near the door here on there.
The,
so let's get the logistics out of the way.
Okay?
Everybody has the handout.
Okay.
Let's begin organizing the,
uh,
the day's work.
I will love begin by taking the snapshot you have in front of you and then using
the data animation on the board to give you a sense of the dynamic process,
which is hidden in the static diagram before you.
Our real interest is in the dynamic process.
And the statics are,
uh,
just like for example,
a quote on the Dow Jones for two 32 in the afternoon.
It's a moving target and the motion is what's interesting.
So that's the first thing we're going to do.
Uh,
the second thing is to look at the dismal science of economics as conceived by
Thomas Malthus,
whose principal work appeared in 1798 and 1800 and which put forward a theory to
the effect that nearly universal poverty was an essential and inevitable fact of
human existence.
Thank God he was wrong.
Third Wheel look at,
uh,
Gregory Clark's exploration of Malthus's world.
Clark is the author of farewell to arms,
which I hope all of you have begun to find your way through.
It's available at labyrinth.
A and Clark is something of a curmudgeon and he offers interpretations which,
uh,
should provoke argument.
For example,
uh,
he interprets,
the demography of England in the Mall Fujian period before the great surge in
the economy,
in each essentially Darwinian terms,
Darwinian both with respect to,
uh,
culture.
Uh,
so social Darwinism but also with respect to biology.
he,
he flirts with the idea that the children of the wealthy were genetically
superior,
uh,
two other children being born in early modern England and that that fact has
something to do with why the Great Economic Serge took place first in England
actually more broadly the United Kingdom.
Finally,
and this is a long agenda.
Finally I'm going to look at economic biology and in particular at what is
called the world demographic transition.
The world demographic transition takes,
it is it is as nearly regular as clockwork and it takes societies from poverty,
short lifespans,
high birth rates,
high death rates
to relative affluence combined with capital relative affluence with long lives,
low birth rates,
low death rates,
and lurking behind the diagram before you is the confluence of the great
economic surge and the world demographic transition.
So 45 minutes from now we should be at that point.
The Diagram on the board is the work of Swedish economist Hans Rosling and it is
a data animation.
It's set up as follows,
a income per capita is on the horizontal dimension and that income per capita is
scaled logarithmically.
I'll switch that out in a minute,
but we'll start with the logarithmic scale.
And on the vertical dimension is a linear scale for life expectancy at birth.
And the bubbles represent countries.
The larger the bubble,
the greater the population of the country.
The bubbles are color coded,
uh,
to the map upper right.
So all of the western hemisphere is shown in yellow,
uh,
Europe and north Asia in orange and so forth,
and notably sub Saharan Africa in blue.
Uh,
you will also find special interest in the green bubbles representing,
uh,
the states of the Middle East.
Now let's just play this,
it,
is this a time series?
It's 200 years of time series.
The bubbles start here in the year 18,
six
and begin moving.
Okay?
Yeah.
Yes.
You're going to need a mic.
Let's hand it to you.
Okay.
Say it again.
Yeah.
They cast doubt on data.
Uh,
what,
what while you're on stage here,
what'd you just say?
Uh,
uh,
is he loud enough to hear in the back
great kind the entire time when there were a few,
a yellow balls or started overtaking all the other things around.
And also there were a few that just kind of went up and down.
You know what the exact same income.
A prison for a long period of time.
Curtis Turner,
some of them seem stuck.
And was it mainly yellow balls or where there some orange balls out there?
No,
no one's going up and down at wanting comfort.
no.
In the ones that were in the lead.
Just a couple of,
okay.
Now
hand the mic to somebody else.
We're just going to pass it around here and get people talking.
No,
no.
Don't hand it on.
MMM.
If you were going to describe to someone who wasn't here,
uh,
what the main pattern was taking into account the two variables,
what would it be?
Okay.
Lower left to upper right and lower left upper right in,
since they're not here,
they don't know what that means.
Okay.
So there is something by and large,
good happening in the data.
Now there are,
uh,
let's pass it on to Yo Egypt tology here.
Um,
does the,
is the progress with respect to biology and wealth evenly distributed or not so
evenly distributed?
Well,
they all
are
still quite loud
and when he actually go backward,
so mine,
it's hard to ask you to remember all that with.
It's a rather complex basket ball game on the screen there.
MMM.
Could we handed on what would you,
if you were a god or Gods Accountant,
uh,
and you are God friendly to humankind.
Uh,
would you say by and large what you're seeing there?
Looks like
the world getting better?
Um,
I would say a general,
but at the same time,
the purple ones,
I think they're blue.
We have,
oh yeah.
Yes.
Compared to the other countries,
even though overall shift to or the upper right hand corner.
Um,
but it wasn't it.
Okay.
Terrific.
Pass the Mike Straight back please.
MMM.
Do the dots or the bubbles show all the inequality involved with all the people
in the world or do they mask something?
Let's take for example,
the,
the enormous upswing.
Look at the a very large light blue bubbles center stage.
It represents India.
Uh,
and as far as we can tell from this graph,
uh,
everybody has the same income and probably works for Wipro in Bangalore,
but in actual fact,
I dunno,
do you know anything about India?
Uh,
okay,
good.
Now we could infer from that that the vertical side,
the vertical dimension of the world economy can be thought of in two phases.
One is the difference between countries measured here by mean GDP per capita and
the differences within countries which would be represented by an income curve
or a wealth curve,
uh,
within each of the countries.
And it turns out that there's quite a lot of inequality inside the bubbles,
uh,
and that,
that inequality is most pronounced in the countries which are in the early
stages of getting rich.
The general pattern.
India is a good example and the fiction work assigned for,
for the course,
a white tiger is about that vertical dimension and how exhilarating it is on the
one hand and the crushing disadvantage it imposes on people who aren't part of
the capitalist development story.
Okay.
Now I want to change the diagram to get a little more
little more finesse here and now I have made the uh,
the income curve linear so it no longer exaggerates movement at the low end of
the scale.
And what I'd like you to do is watch this process
and tell me what you think you're seeing.
These are the same data just projected differently.
Yeah.
Watch for some shooters.
No.
Let me do the last half of that projection once more
and then we'll try to talk about it.
Could we get a mic up and going in that section please?
Yeah.
Okay.
We're going to play from,
let's go around 1900 here.
Yeah.
Okay.
So over here,
who's got the mic?
Can you describe the path that the vast majority of the countries follow?
Okay.
So what,
what's just been said is that the majority of the countries show modest gains in
income per capita and substantial gains in longevity.
So they move vertically more or less vertically and then they pass second base,
so to speak and turn right
across the income field.
Let's run it once more
and I'm going to ask it.
Pass the mic please.
I'm going to ask the next person to take a shot
at
what countries are the shooters,
which defy what I just said.
Yeah.
Who's got the mic?
Who Do you think those shooters are?
Europe and Middle East.
Okay,
well is there,
what are the,
how would you go about
getting huge gains in income per capita without going through the prior step of
having people live quite a while.
How would you get what?
What might make that feasible?
Especially for the green?
You need me to give her half.
Okay.
What don't hold us in suspense.
The green countries might have a lot of oil.
Okay,
so the oil states,
if you bracket the oil states,
you've got a very general worldwide pattern.
Modest gains in income combined with substantial gains in public health,
followed by continued gains in public health though at a decreasing rate
combined with large gains in income per capita.
Now notice that the point made,
made five minutes ago still holds.
When I say that a GDP per capita of a country doubled in a period,
does it mean that the GDP of most people in that country doubled?
And,
and the answer to that,
can we get the mic to center?
Okay.
Well,
let's see.
I'm sorry.
Where's the mic here?
There we go.
Yup,
go ahead.
Not necessarily
the country itself.
Okay.
And let's think of the oil states for a minute.
Uh,
what generally happens to the vast share of the large large shares of revenue
from oil extraction in the middle decades of the 20th century,
which is what we're talking about
individuals.
Okay.
They either remain in the hands of a local elite for the most part or they are
siphoned off by a large international energy company,
but the vast majority of people in such a society often don't benefit very much
from that.
And that becomes a huge issue,
uh,
in world politics and in attitudes toward capitalism.
Okay.
Uh,
the URL of this data,
and I've,
I've explored here less than 1% of its potential,
uh,
is dubdubdub gap minder,
one word,
small letters.org.
Not Com.
Uh,
and it is a resource I would like you to use in the background for this course.
Just out of curiosity,
how many of you had used it before?
Okay.
The rest of you should join in.
This is,
uh,
this is,
the most useful technique for staying awake while thinking about numbers,
uh,
late at night that I have ever seen it.
I showed to grandchildren ranging down to four and they all love it.
All right.
Now this is the diagram that Clark presents at the beginning of his book.
Uh,
it's taken from Angus Maddison,
spelled with two ds who is the lead researcher on everything before 1800 and
economic history these days.
Uh,
and literally every,
if there perhaps 50 bucks a touch on this material and every one of them is
Madison reformulated,
re sliced.
Uh,
these are the four things I told you we were going to do.
We've done one of them.
Uh,
Balsa and Clark refer to the left side before,
uh,
the great surge,
and the biology part about the world's demographic transition concerns the
movement across from left to right,
which stands behind these changes.
Okay.
Now I'm also shouldn't the logic of perpetual poverty poverty,
uh,
Thomas Malthus was a Cambridge wrangler.
That meaning he was at the very top of the student body at Cambridge.
He was a fellow of Jesus College.
He was a devout Christian.
Uh,
and he was a follower of David Ricardo and David Hume.
He was an empiricist,
uh,
he looked at the world around him
and devised a simple model and Clark makes it a good bit more complicated then
Malta stodge.
Uh,
and the reason for that is at Clark wants to make it look like contemporary
economics.
And the actual equilibrium story is very different from the equilibrium story in
a micro economics 101.
Okay.
The
influence of David Ricardo,
there were three great classical economist,
Adam Smith,
whom we're going to study on Wednesday,
David Ricardo,
whom we're not going to study.
And Karl Marx who were,
who were going to study in a week,
the
contribution of Ricardo to Maul fuss was that Ricardo had devised what he called
the iron law of real wages.
And the gist of that was that no matter what the technology,
no matter what the demographics,
the inflation adjusted wages,
play paid to unskilled Labor would always tend toward the bottom of the scale
we've been looking at would always tend toward the level of mere survival or
subsistence as they say.
And in the back of Malthus's thinking is both Ricardo's iron law and the
empirics of 200 years of stagnant wages,
uh,
which the English working class had experienced.
So Ricardo,
Ricardo's main intuition had to do with two forms of earth arithmetic
progression on the left,
counting by hundreds from 100 to a thousand in the production of goods in the
center,
counting by doubling at each cycle,
the population of the same society.
And on the right hand side,
product pork per capita,
uh,
Duh.
The arrived obviously enough by dividing the one by the other.
And let's say the subsistence point is half a bucket per person.
You then this was maltose as big point that everything progresses until you get
to the point where people begin to fall below subsistence level and with a very
unequal distribution of income,
which was,
uh,
inevitable in this period as it is inevitable in the present period or nearly.
So,
uh,
you would find a solution.
Well,
what would be the solutions?
There are two main kinds of solutions.
One,
let's generate a lot more production.
Let's get the scale of production to not be a linear flat line,
but get it to do this,
get production to go north,
uh,
in the same way population does.
And Malthus asserted that that couldn't be done.
Now we'll see.
And we know in our own experience that he was mistaken
production has done exactly that through the introduction of capital intensive
production.
The,
the pessimism in this scenario can be linked to a correct intuition about,
uh,
England or any other agricultural,
in the period from let's say 1200 to 1800.
That's a period Clark chooses.
The first thing that is,
that strikes you about this is they're not making land anymore.
Only the Dutch make new land.
And so you're going to deal with a fixed total of arable land.
And you have,
and let's assume that you have a growing population.
The landmass is static,
the population is growing.
Let's just assume that for the moment.
Uh,
and it's just an assume it's growing in a mall.
Fujian way.
And let's imagine this,
this is a actually a photograph of Berry pickers in Poland in the year 19 nine.
Uh,
all the visual images here are virtually all the visual images here come from
Wikipedia common.
And since we're being filmed,
that's important so that we don't violate anyone's copyright because everything
on Wikipedia common is public domain.
MMM.
And we get seventies,
a little hard to read,
isn't it?
We get land acre,
we've got a hundred units of land for this berry farm and production increases
as we increased the number of workers from one to 12.
Uh,
it starts at 50 with one worker and ends up at 174 bushels or buckets,
uh,
with 12.
So
since the land is fixed,
the marginal impact of each new worker is a little less than the marginal impact
of the worker before.
And the blue series a boils it down to a bushels per worker and we have
cut uh,
50 bushels to 15 bushels by going from one worker to 12 workers,
one.
Now this is all just made up stuff,
but it captures the intuition
about,
about
diminishing returns to intensification of labor and the constants in this story.
Our land and capital,
we're not adding new new land,
we're not adding new capitol,
we're just adding new workers to an existing quantity of land.
So
the,
the
intuition that guided guided Malthus was that as you intensified labor,
you've got diminishing total returns.
The Red Arc,
which implied by perfectly simple logic,
a diminishing rate of production for each worker.
And that intuition is really along that along with the iron law of wages is at
the middle of [inaudible] thinking on the cultural and who here went to a high
school where you learned Latin?
Ready for this one?
We got,
if we got a mic,
where's the mic for him?
Okay.
If none loses no other acquirers.
Yeah.
So the,
and this was Saint Thomas and Saint Thomas was expressing,
uh,
the core conviction of classical Greece though not Rome,
classical Greece and uh,
Christianity in the Middle Ages and early modern times
and
all the scruples,
all the rules about usury being not okay.
That is lending it interest being,
uh,
a violate,
a biblical violation.
All those ideas come from this,
that the total wealth produced by and for mankind,
humankind.
Yeah.
Buy In for humankind is essentially a fixed quantity so that as I get rich,
the act of getting rich imposes relative poverty on others.
In schematic form,
we have a two person,
two person society and going away from the origin means getting richer.
The budget plane is a 45 degree angle where x plus y equals a constant some.
So that movements of getting rich
in either direction along that budget plane imply making others poor.
And this was a deeply held assumption that the best educated and least educated,
uh,
like shared.
And it accounts partly for the,
the underlying trope and Malthus.
And it tells us something about the brilliant originality of Adam Smith and his
contemporaries in the Scottish enlightenment when they said not so.
And
if you represent the same thing with three,
my artwork is a little limited.
You have to imagine that these are three dimensions,
like the two for me,
you and he,
uh,
and that we've drawn that the budget constraint as a plane here.
And then you have to imagine that the green.is on that plane.
Takes a little imagining.
I've stared at it a while.
Um,
but the point is this,
that as you move the dot,
it's impossible to make any mo any movement,
which doesn't disadvantage one of the three people or more
and za Za general assumption,
more or less analogous to zero solemness in game theory.
How many of you've done Ben pollocks course?
Okay?
Uh,
more of us are now it goes to the zero sum theory or to the way a small children
think about sharing Legos,
right?
If I put more in my contraption,
there are fewer for you to use in your contraption.
That is a fundamental assumption in this whole way of looking at the world.
And it corresponds to reality most of the time.
Most of the time in a,
a low capital,
principally agricultural economy,
the world act like this,
new gold doesn't emerge.
New ways of producing at much higher rate are invisible.
And when we get to Mark's,
we'll see that he,
he puts this rabbit in the hat by the way,
he defines the value,
the exchange value and the use value of goods.
He puts this zero sum condition in by the way.
He measures labor and users Labor to define the value of everything.
So that only by imposing surplus hours of work on the Labor on the working
class,
can we get Richard horsefeather's just not true.
Uh,
but that's for another day.
Now,
Clark's explorations,
excuse me here.
Yeah.
Clark,
who's had,
who's had an,
uh,
an hour or more with Clark.
It's a little worrying.
Um,
we've got a bike here.
Is it on?
Um,
what do you think you like Clark or not liking
convincing?
They did.
Okay.
He's convincing.
He's clear.
He is empirical,
right?
There's some kind of a chart or table for everything.
And uh,
he is opinionated.
He's,
it's not the kind of cool dispassion that let's say Rick Levin might value in an
economist.
It's a much more uh,
heated style of argument.
I actually think he's sometimes a little off,
but he's making the argument in a really interesting way.
And one of the things he does is shown in this chart which is taken from I
believe page 31 in his book.
Uh,
and this is total population on the vertical dimension income per capita in the
horizontal dimension.
The red dots represent,
uh,
estimates taken once every 10 years between 1200 and 1600.
And they form an interesting pattern.
The interest,
he combines this with something else.
So it's hard to find,
but if you combine it,
it's almost as if there were a budget plane here
and you can move up and down the budget plane but not through it.
So that the total,
it's,
it's this,
these dots moving away that could be explained Malthus wise,
uh,
or Saint Augustine wise by assuming that there is a fixed total and use,
you can use it to feed more people worse or fewer people better.
And indeed,
if you pull out the data for the time of the great plague population goes down
and per capita income goes up.
Now how exact you think are records of incomes in England in 1380 are okay.
It's,
it's,
it's a stretch to try and make this highly quantitative,
but there it's probably not far off.
Uh,
he then if you then add a 1600 to 1800,
you get something different and you begin to get a surgeon population that does
not correspond to a huge loss in per capita income.
So implicit in that is the idea that we are breaking through budget planes,
not in big ways,
not in elegant ways,
but there is something happening which takes us further and further from the
central tenants of the Malthusian model.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
Clark on real wages from 1200 on the left,
1800 on the right and the spike in the middle is at least partly attributable to
the influence of population decline in the century before it.
Uh,
and I've drawn it so it looks like a much bigger mountain than it is.
It's actually a very gentle swale and you can find a version of it,
no doubt,
more accurate than mine in Clark.
The consumption patterns of ordinary workers in this period were very modest.
Uh,
food and drink accounted for three quarters of spending and I think this is
pretty good.
Empirics
clothing and bedding,
10% housing,
heating,
uh,
light and soap.
Not much.
Life was a pretty dark,
pretty limited.
The level of discretionary spending was a very slight,
there's a general rule called angles law,
and it's,
this is not the angles who worked with marks.
This is Ernst angles lived in the 18 hundreds that as real incomes go up,
the fraction spent on food goes down.
And while that's not exactly a blinding insight,
it nonetheless as the advantage of being a true statement.
And,
uh,
within food,
the proteins principally meat to a lesser degree fish,
uh,
systematically displaced starches a until you get a two hour stage of gluttony.
Uh,
the most interesting piece in Clark is his handling of wealth and reproduction.
And I will,
um,
ask you to read it for yourselves,
but the gist is this,
that
the number of surviving children produced by in each generation was greater
among wealthy families that among poor ones.
And it's pretty easy to think of reasons that might be true,
for example,
uh,
money for heating your house and feeding the babies.
Uh,
but the,
the point that Clark makes of that is more controversial.
Clark wants to say that a cascade of children born at the top of the pyramid,
a cascade of those children were forced to be downwardly mobile for a long
period of time,
populating each level of British society with adults who had a gun life with the
advantages of being top.
And it's easy to make up a story which Clark does to the effect that the
energetic effort you might expect from those people who had been pushed down
might increase the intensity of effort and competition in the economy.
He then,
uh,
makes a series of gestures toward biological Darwinism to the effect that
Britain led the industrial revolution because it had a disproportionate number
of very able people.
And the assumption here is that the rich were more able than the poor.
Uh,
it had a disproportionate number of very able people in all the levels of the
pyramid.
Now
the empirics on that one are really thin.
There's an awful lot of vapor in the intellectual process there.
Uh,
but,
and this is characteristic of Clark.
He's really interesting,
uh,
in throwing out thoughts that should provoke an argument and I should think you
should be able to generate arguments among yourselves on that topic.
Now,
biology gone good.
And I'm going to tell this one in words and then give you the diagram.
In every society in the Malthusian phase,
life is short and babies are plentiful,
so that a typical household might have eight or 10 children of whom perhaps
three or four might survive into adulthood and having survived into adulthood,
many would die at your age or something like it,
and the throughput of human beings was extremely fast.
That's a way to think of it in relation to total population,
then the death rate falls and when the death rate falls,
the birth rate does not respond right away.
In fact,
it takes several generations typically for birth rates to adjust to falling
death rates.
The consequence of that,
there were several,
but the most,
the most fundamental for us is that the population of the world went north very
rapidly.
You're having lots of babies and people are living long lives.
Uh,
then ultimately the birth rate does fall and when it,
we have both the birth rate and the death rate at low levels,
so people live long lives and the population of their societies becomes more or
less static.
Again,
it is then possible to go one step beyond that.
And the one step beyond that is that the birth rate overtakes the death rate on
the low side and the society begins to do two things at once to become smaller
and to have a higher and higher fraction of very old people.
And can anyone name a society that is in that stage?
Yes,
Japan fine.
Uh,
Japan is there.
Russia is pretty much there.
Much of Italy is right on the edge of that much of eastern Europe.
Is there a now the picture,
this is the population surge in every continent.
Uh,
post the slides and I'll post them in a way that you can read them next time.
I promise.
Um,
all the continents turned north,
uh,
beginning sometime after 1800 and that reflects the fact that they are in the
progress of the demographic transition.
Now this is a conventional,
uh,
representation,
of the transition in four phases.
In the first phase we have death and birth rates somewhat unstable but steadily
high.
Then the death rate falls.
The major cause is clean water,
clean water,
uh,
household hygiene.
Uh,
a little bit higher calorie diet.
and at the later stages,
some aspects of modern medicine,
the birth rate doesn't adjust and phase two consists of the period when the
death rate is falling fast and the birth rate remind remains more of us constant
at a high level.
Then phase three,
the birth rate is now stable at a relatively low level and the birth rate is
falling to meet the death rate.
And then in phase four you've got both of them at relatively low levels.
Now we come back at this point to the picture we began with and much of what you
see in this diagram
and much of what you saw in the dynamic animation at the beginning of the hour,
uh,
consists of passage through the demographic transition.
And
most of what you see on the left third in societies that are in Stage two or
early in Stage three,
most of the middle is phase three where the birth rate is falling but you're
still building population.
And the prediction is that we are going to build the world population from
little under 7 million to about eight and a half million,
uh,
before you guys are my age and mostly stage four out on the right.
Now,
the pertinent fact that you need to carry forward from that last little piece is
this.
The
world demographic transition has happened in a sequential fashion.
So there are temporal offsets and societies that are in,
in phase four,
low birth rate,
low death rate,
10 to have a lot of capital and tend to be short on cheap labor
and societies that are in phase two or phase three tend to be long on cheap
labor and short on capital.
And the dynamic of world trade,
which is such an important part of capitalism,
is a way of arbitrage thing between early and late phases in the world
demographic transition.
So that cheap labor is,
maximizes its value by being combined with capitol from phase four societies.
On Wednesday,
we'll come back to the 18th century,
uh,
with Adam Smith who is in my view,
the greatest of all writers on economy and society.